européens s'apprêtent à annoncer un
premier train de sanctions contre les
russes bonjour pierre bénazet on vous
retrouve à bruxelles les 27 veulent
viser les banques russes oui
effectivement on a une série de
sanctions qui n'est pas encore
formellement adopté ça doit être fait
formellement par la ministre la paire
européenne qui sont réunis à bruxelles
c'est eux qui doivent mettre leurs
stempin leur tampon pardon sur ce train
de sanctions elles seront probablement
annoncer au plus haut niveau politique
c'est à dire par les ministres des
affaires étrangères qui sont réunis
actuellement à paris après le forum indo
pacifique
ces sanctions elles ont été décrites par
ursula von der leyen et charles michel
la présidente de la commission et le
président du conseil européen et elles
sont de deux ordres il ya les sanctions
personnelles on ne sait pas exactement
quelle elles seront en revanche on
connaît l'étendue des sanctions
économiques que près par l'union
européenne il y a effectivement l'idée
de viser les banques russes leur
capacité de s'approvisionner et la
banque centrale de russie peut être en
tout cas les banques en tout cas qui
financent les opérations militaires dans
ces territoires autre volet financer la
coupe visé cibler la capacité financière
du gouvernement russe la capacité de
l'état et du gouvernement à son lien
avec les marchés financiers européens de
manière à couper sa capacité à financer
justement sa politique dite d' agression
et d'escaladé dans les territoires en
question de l'est de l'ukraine et puis
troisième volets un volet qui si des
sanctions économiques qui cible
directement les territoires en question
lougansk et donetsk de manière à ce que
dans leur commerce avec l'union
européenne avec l'extérieur ils
ressentent je cite les conséquences
économiques exact de leurs actions
illégales merci pierre bénazet à
bruxelles